Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with,
if I hit the opening video sequence of this paper immediately starts with a
beautiful snow simulation,
which I presume is on a Marsh to a legendary Disney paper from
2013, by the name a material point method for snow simulation,
which to the best of my knowledge was used for the first frozen movie.
I was super excited to showcase that paper when this series started. However,
unfortunately I was unable to get the rights to do it,
but I make sure to put a link to the original paper with the same scene in the
video description. If you're interested now,
typically we are looking to produce high resolution simulations with lots of
detail. However, this takes from hours to days to compute.
So how can we deal with this kind of complexity? Well,
approximately 400 videos ago in two minute papers, episode 10,
we talked about this technique that introduced spacial ad activity to this
process.
The adaptive part means that it made the simulation finer and Courser,
depending on the, what parts of the simulation are visible.
The parts that we don't see can be ran through the course of simulation because
we won't be able to see the difference. Very smart.
The spatial part means that we use particles and subdivide the 3d space into
grid points in which we compute the necessary quantities like velocities and
pressures. This was a great paper on adaptive fluid simulations.
But now look at this new paper.
This one says that it is about temporal adaptivity.
There are two issues that immediately arise first.
We don't know what temporal adaptivity means. And even if we did,
we'll find out that this is something that is almost impossible to pull off.
Let me explain.
There's a great deal of difficulty in choosing the right timestamps for such a
simulation.
These simulations are run in a way that we check and resolve all the collisions,
and then we can advance the time forward by a tiny amount.
This amount is called a timestamp and choosing the appropriate timestamp has
always been a challenge. You see, if we set it to too large,
we will be done faster and compute less. However,
we will almost certainly miss some collisions because we skipped over them.
It gets even worse because the simulation may end up in a state that is so
incorrect, that it is impossible to recover from.
And we have to throw the entire thing out. If we set it to too low,
we get a more robust simulation. However,
it will take from many hours to days to compute.
So what does this temporal activity mean? Exactly? Well,
it means that there is not one global timestamp for the simulation,
but time is advanced differently at different places you see here,
this data T this means the numbers chosen for the timestamps and the blue color
coding means a simple region where there isn't much going on.
So we get away with bigger timestamps and less computation without missing
important events.
The red regions have to be simulated with smaller timestamps because there's a
lot going on. And we would miss out on that.
Hence the new technique is called an asynchronous method because it is a crazy
simulation where time advances in different amounts at different spatial
regions. So how do we test this solution? Well, of course,
ideally, this should look the same as the synchronized simulation.
So that's it. You bet your papers. It does look at that.
Absolutely fantastic. And since we can get away with less computation,
it is faster how much faster in the worst cases,
40% faster in the better ones, 10 times faster.
So 10 of my all-nighter fluid simulations can be done in one night.
Sign me up one at a time to be alive.
This episode has been supported by Lambda. If you're a researcher or a startup,
looking for cheap GPU compute to run these algorithms,
check out Lambda GPU cloud. I've talked about Lambdas,
GPU workstations in other videos,
and I'm happy to tell you that they are offering GPU cloud services as well.
The Lambda GPU cloud can train image net to 93% accuracy for
less than $19.
Lambda is a web based IDE lets you easily access your instance right in your
browser.
And finally hold on to your papers because the Lambda GPU cloud costs less than
half of AWS and Asia,
make sure to go to Lambda labs.com/papers and sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today.
Our thanks to Lambda for helping us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.